at the 2014 Geneva Motor Show
Lamborghini unveiled its latest addition
the hurricane the vehicle represents
everything the Lamborghini is known for
speed and cost it goes zero to 124 miles
per hour in nine point nine seconds and
Kashia about 240,000 dollars but the
Huracan also represents a new approach
to automotive engineering for
Lamborghini here to discuss Stephan
Winkelmann president and CEO of
Lamborghini at wonderful to have you
here Stefan so this is a pretty sweet
ride but it 240 thousand dollars with a
thousand people lined up to buy these I
just have to ask who's fine in terms of
market yeah I mean it's the Middle East
it is us buyers the u.s. is the biggest
market followed by china then we have
the Middle East indeed Japan at the UK
Germany these are the top markets but we
have also big markets which are small in
size but big for us like Singapore
Malaysia Hong Kong but a lot of finite
individuals live how would you
characterize this car and how is it may
be different from what you guys have
done in the past we have I've done or
given to my people a very short briefing
when they started building the car or
developing the car was all about
instinctive technology zigtech
technology sounds a bit weird but it's
very important because it has to be very
fast on the racetrack and it has to be
easy to be driven on normal roads so all
the technology which you have inside has
to fit you like a glove and you have to
feel at home at the very first moment
you have to be better than your driving
skills by driving the hood and how does
this work together the technology and
the actual vehicle the technology needs
to be something which is helping you
yeah like the power-to-weight ratio the
stiffness the double clutch and engine
which is immediately responding a
steaming which is dynamics all these
things together and still be a work of
art right you've got a cap on sales how
many of these are you actually gonna
sell but this is something we have to
see but it's going very well we are you
cap it out right
only allow a certain number of these
colors market at certain time one of the
key issues in the luxury business is to
always sell one car less than the money
so this is the key you gotta keep that
demand going to keep it very very
special let me ask you about the company
itself it's it's a owned by Volkswagen
we're talking about Aston Martin earlier
today as being sort of that separate
standalone unit you know a luxury car as
well not quite the same as Lamborghini
but you know on its own what's the
difference having a big parent company
as opposed to being completely on your
own may know the folks one group has a
lot of brands a dozen we are the most
exclusive one Lamborghini last year we
produced a bit more than 2,000 cars so
we are profiting from the position in
the in the Fox one group that they leave
the responsibility to all what is
happening to us in terms of our any
production and sales and also it's clear
that we have our own profit and loss but
we benefit from synergies and scale for
example do you like being part of a
bigger company sorry you like being part
of a bigger yes but energy and say in
terms of purchasing so we can purchase
for lower price higher quality in terms
of their processes in terms of
production so there is a lot we learn
from them and we've been it gives you
some benefits um you know Carl Pope
former head of the Sierra Club was on
with me earlier this morning and we were
talking about the importance of new
energy and how in some ways it's been
very consumer driven and he pointed to
Tesla as an example of this Lamborghini
is actually trying to go green you think
Lamborghini you don't necessarily think
new energy and green technology but what
are some examples of what you guys are
doing and our consumers asking for it
well what we did in the past in the last
year's we reduce the emissions the co2
emissions with the cars by more than
twenty percent in the last years and we
divided this also from our side from our
factory we are going to be co2 neutral
by next year by 2015 and this is a big
effort for a small company like ours so
we want to keep
the perfect balance between having the
fun of driving those super sports cars
which are not meant to be to go on a
daily base from A to B but this is a
dream which is becoming through and we
want also in future that all the thumbs
are up when you pass by in a Lamborghini
how long you have to wait for one of
these cars before the Aventador the big
one more than a year then this one the
the budokan which we launched at the
geneva auto show is sold out by the
already and they for the year 2014 sold
out for 2014 okay so over a year wait
thank you so much that was great to have
you exactly Stephan Winkelmann president
and CEO of Lamborghini